هذا وقد نقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه عن
مصدر مطلع ان تفسيرات اسرائيل بشان رئيس
حماس في غزه يحيى السنوار غير صحيحه وانه
ليس منفصلا عن الواقع بل لديه استراتيجيه
منظمه في حال استمرار الحرب واضاف المصدر
ان خطه السنوار تتضمن سحب قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي من مواقع في اطار وقف اطلاق
النار لاستعاده القياده والسيطره بينما
ينوي الاحتفاظ ببعض الرهائن كورقه مساومه
للمستقبل و قال المصدر لهيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ان الوسطاء يدركون ان الوقت
ينفد للتوصل الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
وان حماس تستعد لفتره طويله من الحرب اذا
لم يتوصل الى تلك الصفقه في سياق ذي صله
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان مقطع
الفيديو الذي قدم للشباك ظهر فيه محمد
الضيف وهو في وضع نشط وظهر وهو يدخل الى
مكتبه في حي جباليه برفقه حراس امنه واضاف
ضافت ان المقطع المقدمه للشباك اظهر الضيف
بمستوى عال وبشكل مختلف عن الصور المتوفره
له منذ
عقد معنا من نابلس الباحث في الشان
الاسرائيلي عزام ابو العدس استاذ عزام في
تقديرك ما اثر هذه التقديرات التي تبدو
مغيره لما كان يقدم للاسرائيليين واجهزه
استخباراتها خلال الفتره الماضيه عن قائدي
حماس السياسي السنوار والعسكري الضيف
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك ولجمهور
مشاهدي ومستمعي يعني الحقيقه بان هذه
المعطيات الجديده تشير الى ان دوله
الاحتلال ومخابراتها واجهزتها الامنيه
تحولت الى اضحوكه وان احدا لن ياخذها على
محمل الجد بعد اليوم بمعنى ان اسرائيل
كانت تروج لنفسها على مدى سنوات طوال في
المنطقه تحديدا بانها القوه
الاستخباراتيه الاولى في الشرق الاوسط
وبالتالي فشل اسرائيل في معرفه معلومات
دقيقه عن طوفان الاقصى وشبكه الانفاق
واخيرا عن محمد الضيف وعن وضعه الصحي يجعل
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه حقيقه محط الكثير
من التساؤل والتشكك بقدراتها وهذا ربما ما
سنراه بعد الحرب ستتغير خارطه التعاون
الاستخباراتي في الشرق الاوسط ورب ربما
لاسرائيل في العالم بشكل كبير جدا منذ
العام 2006 واسرائيل تروج بشكل كبير جدا
الى ان محمد الضيف يعاني من بتر في ساقيه
وبتر في ذراعه اليسرى و ولا يرى في عينه
اليسرى وبالكاد يتحرك ولا يستطيع ان يتحرك
بدون مرافقين واذكر في العام 2010 2011
يعني تحدثت تقارير بانه مات سريريا والان
تقول دوله الاحتلال وتقول المخابرات بانها
فوجئت ودوله اسرائيل كلها فوجئت بان محمد
الضيف يسير على قدميه يعرج بشكل طفيف
بقدمه اليسرى ويؤدي كل وظائفه اليوميه
والحيويه بشكل ممتاز في الحقيقه هذا ربما
من اكبر علامات الفشل والفشل الكارثي
للمخابرات الاسرائيليه في الحقيقه بان هذه
هذا الواقع كشف ان قوه اسرائيل تقوم على
عنصرين قوه حقيقيه ضئيله جدا وقوه متوهمه
كبيره جدا وهذه القوه المتوهم بددتها
عمليه طوفان الاقصى على البعد العسكري
والبعد الاستخباراتي والبعد الميداني وا
يعني من المفارقه انه قبل اسبوع من هذا
الكشف كان احدى المحطات العبريه وهي
القناه الث ع عرضت كرسي متحرك موجود في
مبنى ما مبنى مقصوف طبعا وقالت بان هذا
الكرسي المتحرك هو لمحمد الضيف بمعنى انه
حتى اللحظه الاخيره كان هذه كانت هذه
المعلومات وكان هذا الاعتقاد السائد هو
الموجود لدى المخابرات الاسرائيليه التي
صدمت وصدم معها المجتمع الاسرائيلي
والاعلام الاسرائيلي بمدى ضحاله معرفتها
عن قطاع غزه ا يبدو تاريخ اسرائيل في
قتالها مع الجيوش النظاميه العربيه نجحا
بشكل استثنائي باستثناء طبعا ما جرى في
عام عام
73 لكن يعني تاريخها مع حركات وا يعني
جماعات النضال المسلحه الفلسطينيه يبدو
فاشلا بامتياز او على الاقل لا يرقى
للمستوى الاول
هل ما تفضلت بذكره من انهيار صوره اسرائيل
وقوتها المتوهم بهذه الصوره سيفتح الشهيه
لمزيد من التجرؤ عليها في المستقبل في
تقديرك طب طبعا وهذا السبب ولهذا السبب
نتنياهو والجيش وتحديدا جيش الاحتلال يصر
حتى النهايه في الذهاب الى هذه الحرب
بالرغم من الخسائر الفادحه التي تعاني
منها دوله الاحتلال وهي ربما الخسائر
البشريه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه الاعنف والاقصى في تاريخها
دوله الاحتلال تريد ان تستعيد قوه الردع
باي ثمن تريد ان تعود شرطي المنطقه وبلط
المنطقه وبالتالي ما حدث في السابع من
اكتوبر دمر هذه الروايه وعطفا على كلامك
اسرائيل منذ العام 2000 لم تحقق صوره
انتصار واحده لم تحقق اي صوره انتصار لا
في لبنان حرب لا في حرب لبنان 2006 عندما
قاتلت حزب الله ولا في انتفاضه الاقصى ولا
منذ العام 2008 في كل حروبها مع قطاع غزه
وبالتالي القوه العسكريه والاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه هي في حاله انحدار وانحدار
شديد جدا وربما جاءت عمليه طوفان الاقصى
لتسرع من هذا الانحدار اكثر واكثر لكن انا
في تقديري دوله الاحتلال خسرت وجودها
وحضورها وقيمتها الاستراتيجيه وهذا ما
سينعكس عليها سلبا بشكل كبير بعد الحرب كل
القوى الاقليميه كانت تعول على اسرائيل
لان تساندها وان تكون حليفتها ايه سواء في
قضاياها الداخليه ام الداخلي والتجسس على
مواطنيها او الوقوف في وجه ايران وبالتالي
عندما يرى العالم والمنطقه فشل اسرائيل
ستنخفض قيمتها الاستراتيجيه طيب استاذنا
الكريم يعني عمليه طوفان الاقصى سبقها
سبقها بعض المظاهر للاهتراء المجتمع
الاسرائيلي خصوصا في مساله التعديلات
القضائيه التي قادها نتنياهو ولقيت معارضه
شديده وظهر بوضوح انقسام المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الان ربما
يعني الحرب وحدت المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ظاهريا لكن سرعان ما ستندلع الانقسامات
والنزاعات مجددا ما مدى قدره المجتمع
الاسرائيلي على الالتئام مجددا واستجماع
قوته بعد انتهاء هذه الحرب في
تقديرك يعني على العكس من مما تفضلت به
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الان لا يزال يعيش في
حاله الجدل وفي حاله الجدل الشديد جدا
لازلنا نرى مظاهر الانقسام رب ما في
الايام الاولى من الحرب كان هذا الكلام
صحيح لكن بعد طول امد هذه الحرب والفشل
الشديد الذي عانى منه نتنياهو عادت مظاهر
الانقسام عاد خصوم نتنياهو التقليديين
يركبون موجه احتجاجات عائلات الاسرى
وبالتالي استدعى نتنياهو اليمين ما يقوم
به نتنياهو يسارع ويسرع بشكل هائل في
تقسيم الشارع الاسرائيلي عندما وقف
نتنياهو في ش وفي مقر الحكومه وقرا رساله
اهالي الجنود الذي تطالبه باستمرار الحرب
كان هذا استدعاء لانقسام شارع ضد شارع في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي